les amis et d'ailleurs ça m'a fait un
peu de peine de voir hier au banc
monsieur Attal et Monsieur Usopp ancien
socialiste
qui qui porte en fin de compte
vous voyez une réforme de droite très
dur très dur parce qu'elle touche encore
une fois la majorité au profit d'une
minorité et qui sûrement il y a quelques
années il aurait combattu vraiment en
bec et ongles c'est comme ça la vie du
coup est-ce que parce que vous m'avez
pas répondu clairement est-ce que
clairement vous allez faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas de vote ou est-ce que
vous sentez qu'il y a un vote nous
pensons que les articles suivants
l'article 7 mérite beaucoup plus de
débats que ce qui nous est annoncé donc
voilà donc on va nous présenter nos
amendements nous allons présenter nos
arguments nous allons défendre nos
explications de vote nous allons faire
parole sur article vos amendements parce
qu'il y a quasiment 4000 amendements de
la goutte je ne retirez pas vos
amendements pour aboutir à votre final
les amendements du groupe socialiste je
ne parle que de moi que de mon groupe
les amendes du groupe c'est moins de 500
amendements moins de 500 dans ce que pas
énorme après il y a des amendements
individuels qui ont été déposés et
pourquoi ils ont été les poser et bien
en prévention
[Musique]